nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
within a roughly 24-hour period the joe
biden presidency
took a major major hit with joe bob
uh joe biden not joe bomber joe biden
bombing
syria while appearing to back away
from requiring the inclusion of a 15
federal minimum wage in the covid relief
bill that's working its way
through congress now on the minimum wage
the biden administration
has come out and said we're still
committed to that we might just do it
outside of the coveted relief bill we'll
get into that
in a moment but not a good 24 hours for
joe biden here
on thursday joe biden launched
airstrikes in syria
now why did joe biden do this well he
explained it or at least tried to
in a letter to congressional leadership
joe biden said the strike was quote
pursuant
to the united states inherent right of
self-defense
as reflected in article 51 of the united
nations charter biden further explaining
that quote
at my direction on february 25th u.s
forces conducted a targeted
military strike against infrastructure
in eastern syria
used by iran-supported non-state militia
groups
those non-state militia groups were
involved in recent attacks against
united states and coalition personnel
in iraq including the february 15
attack in irbil iraq which wounded one
u.s service member
wounded four u.s contractors including
one critically
and killed one filipino contractor
however we are right back
to the same issue of a president
obtaining authorization
for use of military force through
congress
this was an issue with barack obama this
was an issue with donald trump
this is now an issue with joe biden so
there are two things here
first are the particulars of these
strikes
this is just the latest of 20 years
of american foreign policy all over
again since 9 11.
they attacked u.s personnel in iraq
so we're retaliating okay well so what's
the point here the point is
to send the message that we won't
tolerate this
all right and then what happens next the
attack sours
any good will that there was to the
united states
nothing improves we rinse and repeat for
another five years of the same stuff
so i don't really care to debate whether
this particular case well
there was a service member wounded and
four contractors and a filipino killed
and so
this was justified because of that
attack
to be honest maybe it was under this
completely
sort of deranged uh uh framework
in which we've been operating for the
last 20 years maybe it was justified
in that framework maybe it wasn't the
questions are
two number one will we ever have a
president
who actually dislodges the decades-long
status quo
of repeating things that don't work and
just extend
the status quo this obviously isn't
going to do that regardless of your
opinion about this particular strike
and then further we once again get to
this issue of an authorization to use
military force
this all goes back to resolutions from
2001
and 2002 which were passed
to give the president the ability to go
after
the then president george w bush to go
after those who did the september 11th
attacks
it was used to go into war with iraq in
2003
which didn't do the september 11th
attacks but
then it has been subsequently used
to as the legal justification
for a whole bunch of these different
strikes u.s strikes in syria u.s strikes
elsewhere
and presidents always point back to the
2001
uh aumf authorization for the use of
military force
as to why they can do it but can they
many democrats say no when it's a
democrat in office many republicans also
say no although they tend to shut their
mouths
when it's a republican in the oval
office doing the same thing
so we can't be hypocrites here if the
aumf didn't cover trump stuff
in syria didn't cover obama didn't cover
things george w bush
did outside of the scope of responding
to 911 it can't cover things that joe
biden does either so
we just have to pick one and i believe
at this point 20 years later
the aumf is definitely no good
so for me this is beyond any debate
about this particular incident this
particular bombing
this is about more of the same once
again in these never-ending conflicts
and then coinciding with the minimum
wage disaster
joe biden included a 15 coin rather
coinciding with the serious stuff is the
minimum wage disaster
joe biden included a fifteen dollar
minimum wage in his coveted relief bill
on technical grounds it's not going to
be in the senate version of the covid
relief bill why
the senate parliamentarian elizabeth
mcdonough
says a 15 minimum wage provision doesn't
comply with rules governing
what can be done via budget
reconciliation so
almost certainly even though kamala
harris
could overrule that decision by the
parliamentarian
the senate will likely pass a version of
covid relief
not including a 15 minimum wage it'll go
back to the house
the house will have to vote on that and
it will pass
without the 15 minimum wage i don't
believe
that it's clear that a standalone
bill on a 15 minimum wage makes it
actually happen
that's increasingly what the biden
administration is pointing to saying
it's it's too big a step to override the
senate parliamentarian
we are committed to the 15 minimum wage
but we will do it separately
i don't know if that will happen it's
not clear to me that every democratic
senator
wants a 15 minimum wage so overall
not a good 48-hour period for joe biden
and we will of course be following this
this week
republicans know that they didn't
suppress enough of the vote in 2020.
if they had suppressed enough of the
vote in november
trump would be president right now
instead of joe biden so republicans have
launched
a nationwide voter suppression effort
it's already underway with 253 different
bills
in 43 states many of these bills
premised on false claims
that donald trump actually won the 2020
election now you have to give them
credit
they see the problem and they're trying
to fix it the problem is
record voter turnout in november gave
the election to joe biden
as they see it too many people voted
so the solution is to prevent people
from voting now all of these bills
in some way attempt
to restrict voting and ballot access the
brennan center for justice has a great
analysis on this
and the playbook includes strategies
we're familiar with make it more
difficult to register to vote
by banning voter registration that's
automatic by shortening registration
windows that's one part of the playbook
purge voters from voter rolls so they
believe they're registered they show up
and they're not
you can do that by putting in place
looser and looser guidelines for when
people can be unregistered
and removed from voter rolls third part
make voter id requirements stricter and
stricter
which we know disproportionately impacts
poorer people now how do they do this
the way you do it it's almost evil
genius
in order to get the voter id is free as
they say
but in order to get the voter id you
require
more and more documents that you have to
bring with you
to be given the voter id and these are
documents
which poorer people are less likely to
have
people with more housing instability are
less likely to have retained
and some of the documents you need to
get your free voter id
cost money to get okay and they're
documents that take
time to get when people can't afford to
take time off from work to deal with
bureaucracy
so that's how you deal with this uh
quote problem
of too many people voting through voter
id another approach is you add elements
of
voter intimidation to voting you
increase poll watchers that type of
thing
a few examples georgia senate
republicans have introduced a bill
that would end no excuse absentee voting
entirely meaning
you can't just say i want to vote
absentee because i want to
they restrict the reasons that you can
give to vote absentee
georgia house republicans have their own
sweeping bill
which would reduce the early voting
period again just shorten the days the
number of days people can vote
montana republicans want to end same-day
voter registration
missouri republicans want a new voter id
requirement
new hampshire republicans want to ban
out-of-state college students
from voting in new hampshire and they
want to end same-day registration
iowa republicans already approved a bill
that would shorten voting hours
on and on and on now at the same time
that there are bills
uh proposed to limit voting there are
also bills proposed mostly by democrats
to expand voting access and hopefully
some of those will pass
but republicans aren't even pretending
they're they haven't been pretending for
a long time
they openly want to win not by winning
the hearts and minds of people with
policies that voters will like
they want to win by making it hard to
vote disproportionately for people that
are statistically more likely to vote
for democrats
at some point and i believe that that
point is now
the only way to deal with this is to
pass national election reform
and to pass it in a way that it
overrides state limitations that
republicans want to impose
and to prevent the next president from
just undoing it
easier said than done but is there any
better time to do it than when democrats
control the white house
the senate and the house of
representatives for at least
the next two years the time to do it has
to be now
and we'll be talking more about what
that effort could look like
in the future find me on twitter at
dpakman let me know your thoughts on
this
massive dump of voter suppression bills
across the country from republicans the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about half the water that other shower
heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now because of how powerful it
is
it only takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
despite what you might read in the
youtube comments about our show
we are not funded by big corporate
donors
or rich dudes with a bunch of cash or
anything like that
we're mostly funded by individual
memberships on our website
joinpakman.com and i would love for you
to grab such a membership february was a
tough month for us
from the standpoint of memberships i
would love for you to sign up get
instant access
to the bonus show and the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
joinpacman.com is the place to do it and
you can get a discount
uh anybody who wants it can have it
better 21
is the coupon code cpac is the
conservative political action conference
it culminated yesterday in an erratic
and delusional crescendo
with former president donald trump's
first speech since leaving office on
january 20th
the speech started of course 70 minutes
late for no
good reason endlessly delayed and was
rife with all of the things we would
expect from donald trump lies about what
he did
lies about what he didn't do lies about
what joe biden has done so far
lies about what joe biden has not done
so far lies about immigrants
lies about covid lies about the economy
a victimhood complex that would be a
worthy of a few decades of
psychoanalysis and of course
yes false claims that donald trump
actually won the election
the speech was expected to be a fidel
castro like two hours or more
in the end it was about 90 minutes trump
appeared to sort of
skip a bunch of the end when he and the
crowd
seemed increasingly bored by the things
that he was saying
the crowd was also bored and silent
during many parts of the speech they
were most riled up and this tells you a
lot about
the state of the republican party the
crowd most titillated
when trump called kovid the china virus
they erupted with a standing ovation
when trump claimed he won the election
the crowd went nuts
and when trump talked about the new
wedge issue of
transgender women in sports the crowd
also gave a standing ovation those were
the things that were most interesting to
the crowd
i can't possibly cover the whole speech
i want to touch on some key moments
donald trump opened the speech by
claiming that his presidency was the
most successful in history
despite losing and becoming one of of
only 10 one-term presidents
trump says his was the most successful
to so many wonderful friends
conservatives and fellow citizens in
this room and all across our country i
stand before you today
to declare that the incredible journey
we've begun
together we went through a journey like
nobody else there's
never been a journey like it there's
never been a journey so successful
we began it together four years ago
interesting to take a presidency
with no accomplishments a globally
humiliating failure on the pandemic and
a huge electoral loss and call it the
most successful
but okay the crowd i guess liked it most
importantly donald trump making it clear
he is not starting a new party and the
the president the former president
rightly identifies
that starting a new party would make
republicans lose for a long time
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party it's going
to unite and be stronger than ever
before i am not starting a new party
that was fake news fake news no
wouldn't that be brilliant let's start a
new party and let's divide our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that so trump's analysis
there
is correct uh the the best assessment is
the reports were accurate at the time
trump was
thinking of starting a new party but he
was talked out a bit
for this reason that it would fracture
the right and they wouldn't win for a
very long time which was also
our assessment of that idea as usual
donald trump
cites out of context and apparently
meaningless polling numbers
about how popular he is he can't get
away from this take a listen
mr mclaughlin just gave me numbers that
nobody's ever heard of before
more popular than anybody that's all of
us it's all of us
those are great numbers and i want to
thank you very much those are incredible
numbers i came here and he was giving me
95
97 92
[Applause]
no one has ever been more popular than
trump
according to mr mclaughlin the reality
is trump is the only president
never to pull 50 approval throughout his
presidency
and the only president to leave office
with an approval
so low it was 29 approval
when donald trump left office and then
after all of these lies donald trump
pulls out the big lie
that he won and maybe he will even win
the presidential election a third time
alluding to maybe running in 2024
and the crowd goes nuts but who knows
who knows i may even decide
to beat them for a third time okay
importantly though donald trump did not
announce his 2024 candidacy it was
rumored he might at yesterday's speech
he said he might run and that we'll see
we'll get to that later trump again
claims that
if the election had been fair he would
have won i said it
had we had a fair election
the results would have been much
different and then donald trump launched
another
brutal but completely ignorant attack on
wind power you knew he would do it how
bad is wind power so i talk about it all
the time at cpac right we went to
cpac remember last i said we're gonna
watch the president
well uh alice uh the wind isn't blowing
i don't believe we'll have any
electricity remember we would
we would kid but i wasn't actually
kidding it's
such an important such an expensive form
of energy
it's so bad for the environment it kills
the birds
it destroys the landscapes and remember
these are structural columns with fans
on them
they wear out and when they wear out all
over the country you see them
nobody takes them down they're rotting
they're rusting
how this is environmentally good for our
country and it costs
many many times more than natural gas
which is clean it costs many more
and can fuel our great factories wind
can't do that and
clearly donald trump understanding
nothing about
wind power that's the takeaway uh wind
power is bad for the environment and he
says it kills birds
it's not bad for the environment wind
turbines
do kill some birds but fossil fuel power
kills way more animals and trump doesn't
seem to care about that at all
it's merely a talking point that does
well with the uninformed crowd
then donald trump again claims he won
the election twice and the crowd just
loves it famous for the rest of their
lives
we won the election twice i mean you
know think about it
the task for our movement and then
donald trump
introducing the new wedge issue
gets a standing ovation the issue is
trans women in sports now i think it's
crazy i think it's just crazy what's
happening
we must protect the integrity of women's
sports so important
after
[Applause]
[Music]
he then went into a mildly transphobic
rant
about that issue and the crowd
re-energized by that now this next part
is really important
donald trump is not starting his own
party i mentioned that earlier
but he's going out hard against
republicans
he doesn't like republicans he sees as
not loyal enough to him
and he calls out a long list of
republican senators and members of the
house here
democrats don't have grandstanders like
mitt romney little ben sass
richard burr bill cassidy susan collins
lisa murkowski pat toomey
[Applause]
and in the house tom rice
south carolina adam kinzinger
dan newhouse anthony gonzalez that's
another beauty
fred upton jamie herrera butler
peter meyer john catko david
valadeo and of course the warmonger
a person that loves seeing our troops
fighting liz cheney how about that
[Applause]
so while donald trump did recognize that
starting his own party would be bad for
the right
he apparently doesn't think that
attacking other republicans will be bad
for the right
maybe he's right i don't know i guess
we'll have to wait and see what impact
that has but trump going
very hard against other republicans
and then trump plugging a website
where you can give money he now says
he's committed to helping republicans in
2022
and he has a website where you can
donate more money he pitches that next
there's only one way to contribute
to our efforts to elect america first
republican conservatives and in turn to
make america great again and that's
through
save america pac and donald j trump.com
so go out there and do whatever you can
because we're going to help a lot of
great people now based on his grifting
tens of millions of dollars to quote
fight the election results
which he just kept for himself just
months ago
i'm skeptical that your donations to
this new grift
are really going to go to what he claims
they're going to go for and then as the
speech started winding down nearly 90
minutes after it started
donald trump teasing that he might run
in 2024.
with your help we will take back the
house
we will win the senate and then
a republican president will make a
triumphant
return to the white house and i wonder
who that will be
i wonder who that will be
who who who will that be i wonder
so yeah the important takeaways
trump has learned nothing he's still
repeating the same lies
the crowd still mostly loves it so maybe
it's the correct lies to repeat
i don't know he's uh not yet committed
to running in 2024 but he's not starting
his own party
and he's very willing to attack
republicans who don't
100 percent lay down for trump to walk
all over them
those are the takeaways and beyond that
the bit players during the entire cpac
weekend
mostly sucked up to donald trump or at
least avoided direct
criticism of donald trump so the overall
takeaway
is this remains the party of trump for
the time being
and mitt romney's statement last week
that the nomination is trump's if he
wants it in 2024
as of today march 1st still holds true
things can change i still think that if
a lot of these trumpian
elected officials like bobert
marjorie taylor greene madison cawthorne
now accused by like 30 women of
harassment during college
if they go down in flames in 2022
it starts to change the picture for
trump in 2024 but we're getting ahead of
ourselves
after the break we'll look at a few
other key moments from cpac there
weren't that many
and we'll also have more cover coverage
of this on the show's instagram page
rapidly approaching 100 000 followers on
instagram
you can find us there at david pakman
show the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show so
interestingly enough there's not
actually that much to cover from cpac
the conservative political action
conference we covered donald trump's
speech
earlier in the show and there's only a
few other things to say
cpac you know at one point cpac really
was one of the more important
right wing conferences with many big
players from the american right
and this past weekend cpac was more like
a
racist transphobic religious
comic-con than a serious gathering and i
don't even want to insult comic-con like
comparing cpac to comic-con has a lot of
really interesting things comic-con has
lots of
uh great sci-fi writers and a lot of
interesting things i think i would learn
a lot more actually
by going to comic-con than i would from
cpac so i'll put it a different way
i would much rather go to comic-con than
cpac not only would it be more
informative
i'd meet more interesting people and
people more grounded in reality
in any case comic-con sort of analogies
aside
one of the notable speeches was ted cruz
ted cruz is the now
very much beleaguered senator who
recently had
had to cut his cancun vacation short
because it exploded into a public
relations nightmare when he fled to
mexico with his family
as his own constituents in texas were
without power
sometimes without heat struggling even
to get food water had to be boiled
many times with electricity they didn't
have ted cruz went to cancun
so ted cruz goes to cpac and he appeared
to have sort of like a manic episode his
speech ended with a completely
hyperbolic
crescendo of screaming which we'll get
to but ted cruz first opening
with a joke about wanting to be back in
cancun i guess
god bless cpac
[Applause]
i gotta say orlando is
awesome
it's not as nice as cancun
but it's nice so
really well-crafted comedy by the
republican senator really a wordsmith
and
public speaking expert as you can see
then
he ridiculously went after
senator bernie sanders and congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
we're actually going to come back to the
aoc part a little bit later but take a
look
bernie is wearing mittens
and aoc is telling us she was murdered
and the media desperately desperately
desperately wants to see
a republican civil war so this is like i
can't figure out if this is bad
comedy or terrible political speech i
actually can't tell which it is maybe
it's both
ted cruz then going into an anti-mask
rant they're still on this mask stuff by
the way
how many of y'all have eaten at a
restaurant in the last six months
can i just stop and say how strange the
rules are right now i want to understand
how this virus works so when you walk in
you got to put your mask on sadly i've
got two
you walk in you got to put your mask on
you sit down you take your mask off
see apparently the virus is actually
connected to elevation
now remember this is all about science
it's actually it may not be elevation i
think it's
it's that there are hormones that are
released in your thighs when you're
sitting
so you can sit at the table and there's
no virus being transmitted
but if you stand up put the mask on who
wrote this stuff
for ted cruz they should really be
writing for snl or the daily show i mean
great great material
for how you would ridicule a politician
giving a speech uh and then here is
where ted cruz
starts to kind of escalate and seemingly
get more and more manic
well they're saying everybody can get
immunized
we can have herd immunity everywhere and
we're gonna wear masks for the next 300
years
and by the way not just one mask two
three four
you can't have too many masks
how much virtue do you want a signal
this is just dumb
ted cruz working himself up to actually
being sort of short of breath now
and of course as i've said many times
before
the reason that public health experts
have to be
so cautious in what they say
about what an individual getting
vaccinated means
is that so many people like ted cruz
like his followers like the people at
cpac
they are desperate to disregard all
guidelines and measured
measures oh one person got vaccinated
let's hold a 50-person indoor party of
course
reasonable people know that vaccination
opens new doors for people and of course
as more people get vaccinated we will be
able to start backing off of all the
guidelines
but because of people like ted cruz
spreading disinformation
that we never needed masks and all of
this stuff all along was bogus
public health experts have to say just
because you got vaccinated don't go nuts
just because five percent of the
population has had two doses i don't or
whatever the number is i'm not caught up
we'll have a report tomorrow doesn't
mean everything can be disregarded
uh ted cruz now is and i've seen
unfortunately facebook friends posting
this too
if the vaccines change change nothing
why would i get a vaccine and of course
as we talked about last week in our
segment about
vaccine alarmism that's not the case but
the reason people have to continue being
so careful
with what they say from a public health
standpoint
is because of people like ted cruz okay
i'll i'll
interrupt this rant and do more of it
tomorrow
then here's the absolute end to ted
cruz's speech
screaming at the top of his lungs and
really appearing to lose it
in the immortal words of william wallace
freedom
so that's a senator one of 100 senators
in the collegial and storied legislative
body that is the united states
government
the united states senate within the
united states government screaming
at the top of his lungs quoting mel
gibson and braveheart
as an apparently defiant and principled
stand against wearing a mask during a
pandemic
this was one of the highlights of cpac
if you can imagine
most of the rest of it not even worth
covering
but one theme that we did see throughout
cpac
is the inability to accept that donald
trump lost then i want to talk about
that next
a cpac was mostly worthless the second
day
uh was a complete throwaway nothing
worth covering happened on the second
day saturday
which is good because i was in bed with
a fever from my second coronavirus
vaccine dose
i wouldn't have been able to cover any
of it anyway fortunately in a sense
there was nothing worth covering but one
theme that sort of wound its way
throughout friday and saturday
and sunday is that cpac attendees
were unwilling to accept that donald
trump
lost we are what just a few days short
of
form december january february march
were days
from being four months beyond the
election
which joe biden easily won more easily
than the margin by which trump won in
2016
and cpac speakers i guess because
they're still
sort of cow towing to trump placating
trump
will not admit that trump simply lost
let's go through some examples
here is tom fitton from judicial watch
this is one bizarre guy with some kooky
ideas
saying trump had the votes on election
day but
vote totals changed as ballots were
counted can you imagine take a listen
on election day president trump had the
votes to win the presidency
these vote totals were changed because
of unprecedented and extraordinary
counting
after election day now in a literal
sense
what tom fitton says is true
votes that were cast by election day
were counted after election day legally
as
always happens with absentee ballots and
as those votes were counted the results
changed
yet that is in a technical sense it is
true he wants you to believe something
illegal happened of course it didn't
then larry kudlow donald trump's former
economic advisor talking about polling
from last october
he's put we have ballots that we counted
now
you talk about polling beforehand but
larry kudlow
is talking about polling from before the
election comments on that
i was interested last october a gallup
poll said 56 percent of americans
believed at that time that they were
better off
than they were four years ago despite
the fact that they had been in the
pandemic they still believed
that they were better off that's a trump
thing
that's a trump thing
and then josh hawley gets a standing
ovation
after reminding the crowd that he
voted not to certify the election
results on january 6th
this was part of what incited the
violent riot
and the crowd gives josh hawley a
standing ovation you know on january the
6th
i objected during the electoral college
certification maybe you heard about it
i did i stood up
i i guess the crowd believes that they
are being
principled in some way by
giving josh hawley this standing ovation
for an action holly's action much like
ted cruz and others
that melded with rudy giuliani's trial
by combat thing and all this other stuff
and of course
trump's speech saying let's go to the
capitol and led to a riot the crowd
cheering it then matt schlapp who runs
the american conservative union that's
the organization that
organizes cpac saying that what happened
in november
it was an unconstitutional power grab
in leaving cpac it would be do all you
can
to any member that we have any influence
over to explain to them that it's
unacceptable
to have this unconstitutional power grab
on elections
so that what we saw this election will
be what you will see
every single election and we have to
fight
it now it wasn't an unconstitutional
power grab
it was that joe biden won they still
can't accept it and why should they
trump still hasn't accepted that hillary
got more votes than him in 2016.
it's been five years and trump doesn't
accept
those results so of course they're not
going to accept the results from almost
four months ago
since they think they won they won't be
changing their strategy either
and here's house minority leader gives
me great pleasure to say minority leader
kevin mccarthy
laying out the plan listen we're going
to continue to do exactly what we did in
the last election
okay i mean if you think you won i guess
you do the same thing
and uh they are also as we talked about
earlier in the show
planning to suppress more votes they're
already scheming to do it
we gave you a report earlier in the show
about 253
different bills and measures to suppress
voting
across 43 states republicans believe
they won i guess
certainly they don't want to change
their strategy but they didn't suppress
enough votes and that's what they're
going to try to do
now one last hilarious moment this is
this is my favorite
right side broadcasting is one of these
online based right wing uh
channels i don't think they're as big as
newsmax and oan
but they're big enough that they're
worried about getting sued and
uh cpac was rife with anti-science
discussions related to covid
and rife with anti-fact discussions
related to the election
right side broadcasting during a cpac
panel discussion
about the election cut away to read one
of the funniest disclaimers i've ever
heard to try to protect themselves from
legal liability
three different states 42 000 votes 45
000 votes something like that and we
would have had an electoral college
uh vote of 269 to 269. there's a lot of
sensitive topics
being talked about right now we want
everyone to do your own research
in regards to what they're talking about
in this discussion right now
anything with the election or anything
like that so it's important to do your
own research i know there's several
outlets here that are able to
completely uh broadcast all of this
content
uh for you with any disclaimer at all
but unfortunately here at right side
broadcasting we must
jump in here and put a small disclosure
that
we want you to do your own research and
it's very important that we do that yeah
absolutely just quickly although we are
broadcasting these speakers we want to
provide you with that
it does not mean that we necessarily
believe or support
all of their beliefs of every single
speak speaker talking today so make sure
that you
research everything you talk to your
healthcare position physicians whether
it's regarding covid
or medical information and if it's
election related just
look it up and look everything up and we
are just not endorsing any speakers for
the event again we are simply
broadcasting these speakers talk to your
healthcare physicians
there's so many election lies and so
many bogus medical claims being made at
cpac
that right side broadcasting has to cut
away
and issue this absolute gold disclaimer
and at one point uh they also
um they interrupted mike lindell from my
pillow
during an interview i'm not even going
to play it because it's so stupid but
they interrupted and said
uh you know we have to be really careful
mike because we could lose our entire
thing and mike lindell said oh oh oh
you can find that clip if you want like
an extra bonus clip
but this is where my coverage of cpac
ends we're going to take a quick break
we'll do more vaccine stuff after the
break and many more things glad you're
with us on this first
show in march 2021
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio
david patreon.com show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so last week i did a segment that i
received a ton
of positive feedback about and it
generated some really good discussions
about
deprogramming cultists and those who
have been brainwashed by disinformation
as a reminder the youtube video was
called i confronted an
anti-vaxxer it didn't go well
well and in that video i chronicled
an email exchange i had with a coveted
anti-vaccine person who emailed me
saying that
i was being paid to promote vaccines
which aren't really vaccines and which
don't work anyway
and which are killing people and when i
asked her for the sources
for that information she ran away and
provided
nothing well this segment aside from
being instructive in itself
also generated a ton of responses from
even more anti-vaccine people all coming
out of the woodwork to attack me
all equally uninformed all sending me
even more
outrageous emails it was like cascading
anti-vaxx
inbox explosions so because people
found last week's clip so interesting i
chose
just one i mean i can't respond to all
these i chose
one of the subsequent emails to respond
to
and i'll show you how that one went and
it's basically just as bad
all right the the follow-up i got an
email from a woman named
brittany who wrote to me responding
to my email exchange from last week
with amy saying quote how can you
promote these unsafe vaccines
i'm sure you heard of the nurse who
fainted after getting
her coveted vaccine and then they tried
to replace her
after she died because of it
brittany sends me a link to a website
called
leaseahumanelife.wordpress.com
which is some kind of poorly formatted
blog
which claims that the nurse who fainted
after getting the vaccine
is actually dead and has been replaced
by a look-alike but a poor enough
look-alike
that i guess britney can tell it's not
actually the same person
now initially i ignored this because
it's so
dumb and it's been so widely debunked we
know that the nurse didn't die
we know there's lots of people who just
faint around needles
we don't know if this nurse fainted as a
a rare reaction
to being vaccinated specifically by this
vaccine
or she just faints around needles a sort
of vasovagal incident but most
importantly she didn't die
but i didn't respond because it seemed
like a waste of time
but brittany was not to be ignored
brittany was persistent and she followed
up emailing me again
saying i sent you proof about the
vaccines causing deaths
i haven't heard back so i assume either
you haven't had
time to look at it or just like everyone
else
you don't want the truth fraud is a
serious thing
and that's what all this is so i don't
understand
why things are being covered up it will
all come out in court
so i don't know what else to say just
that at least if you took time to read
this
thanks for your time so now i did write
back
uh since britney really seems to want an
answer
i wrote back to brittany and i said that
nurse didn't die
none of your links were reputable here
is a reputable
source reuters and i link brittany
to a reuters article which reports
including
naming the nurse and citing actual
statements from people on the record
the nurse who fainted after covid19
vaccine did not die
catholic health initiatives memorial
hospital in chattanooga tennessee
where nurse manager tiffany dover works
confirmed to reuters
that she is well to which our friend
brittany wrote
remember britney first was saying the
fact that you're not responding it's
because clearly what i sent you is true
the nurse died
i write britney back and explain to her
what actually is going on
and brittany writes back and without
addressing the facts says
simply quote i don't understand how you
could cover for these people
you know the proof is solid but that's
on you
justice will come now as we discussed
last week
every time i i show something like this
or some of the hate mail that i get
people write in and say david these
aren't people who are just
wrong these people are clearly suffering
from mental illness
often paranoid delusions now i certainly
can't diagnose that i don't know how my
audience can
but the mental illness component in
general is something that can't be
ignored
but either way taking this at face value
someone who believes
lissa humane without any citations
over a specific report from reuters with
source links and naming individuals that
are giving statements
that's not someone i think i can get
back to reality mental illness or not
that's just a pragmatic reality and the
problem
ultimately is we need to get these folks
vaccinated in order to build herd
immunity so it's not merely an academic
or theoretical thing to figure out like
how can we reach them
if they all don't depending on how many
of them they are
and based on the herd immunity numbers
we're looking at right now
requirements that we're looking at now
at least some of these folks are going
to have to get vaccinated for us to
really achieve herd immunity that's my
only concern
you know saying this person is just nuts
or this is a bad person
or this is a liar or this is someone
who's mentally ill it's
a curious question but less relevant to
actually figure figuring out how to deal
with this
and uh unfortunately i don't have an
answer i'm interested in hearing from
you if you think you have one
um while republican senator ted cruz was
flying back and forth from cancun mexico
late two weeks ago democratic new york
congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez was raising
millions of dollars for ted cruz's texas
constituents
and was volunteering at the houston food
bank for ted cruz's constituents
now did ted cruz thank aoc
no he didn't did texas governor greg
abbott
thank aoc and beto o'rourke and all the
other democrats who fundraised for
texans
they didn't did they thank aoc and other
democrats
who flew to texas and went to work at
the houston food bank to help ted cruz's
constituents
no they didn't thank them for that
either either and when ted cruz
finally mentioned aoc it was friday
during his cpac speech we saw this clip
earlier during our ted cruz clip
here it is again here is ted cruz making
fun of aoc
for her experience during the january
6th trump riots
bernie is wearing mittens
and aoc is telling us she was murdered
and the media desperately desperately
desperately wants to see
a republican civil war now what is ted
cruz
even talking about aside from just being
a disgusting human being
ted cruz is referring to the twitter
exchange
in which aoc had tweeted that quote
there must
or not not quote she tweeted that there
must be an investigation of robin hood
for their role in the gamestop fiasco
and ted cruz retweeted aoc saying
fully agree and aoc instead of
sort of accepting ted cruz's i guess
bipartisanship
um aoc tweeted a rebuke of ted cruz
saying quote i'm happy to work with
republicans on this issue
where there is common ground but you
almost had me murdered three weeks ago
so you can sit this one out happy to
work with
almost any other republicans that aren't
trying to get me killed
in the meantime if you want to help you
can resign
now some people loved this response from
aoc saying it's aoc standing by her
principles regardless
of whether on this one issue ted cruz
agrees with her
others were sort of upset that aoc
responded aggressively to a senator
saying
i want to do i agree with you on this
particular issue
now ted cruz is so disgusting that i do
tend to side with aoc on this particular
one
but this is less about aoc and more
about
the fact that even republicans
from texas who did nothing for their
constituents during the storm
can't simply thank aoc for what she did
do for texas
aoc has done more for texans than their
own senator
dozens of people died in texas aoc
helped them
raised money went to texas went to a
houston food bank and worked
ted cruz went to cancun and he's making
fun of aoc
the the you know uh everybody lighten up
is the type of thing people say when
they failed to deal with something
serious
and they want everybody else to take it
less seriously
that's how they tell everyone not to
worry about it now maybe
people like ted cruz see aoc as a sucker
for helping texans what i mean is
she didn't have to do it like legally
speaking texans aren't her constituents
she's the sucker maybe that's the view
ted cruz has
aoc was suckered into helping people
who don't even get to vote for her one
way or the other
either way these are really pathetic
people
and we can only hope that they are
eventually held accountable and like i
said last week
unfortunately with ted cruz's next
election if he chooses to run for
re-election
still four years away i'm not super
optimistic
that this entire fiasco is really going
to hit him in any way that it will
actually hurt i hope to be wrong
but i mean you know when a democratic
new york congresswoman is doing more for
texas constituents than their own
senator who's
trying to escape to the beach in mexico
you know that one of two things is going
on number one
either voters really don't care what
their elected officials do
and they care only about what they say
which is quite probable
uh or two there may not
we we may just not have a system that
has consequences
for bad actors in the political system
in which case we have to figure out
other ways to win these elections
probably some combination of the two we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 david p
um i got a lot of voicemails about cpac
a few dozen of them i'm going to play
one for you here and
you may have noticed that the sort of
slogan or motto for cpac this year the
conservative political action conference
was america uncanceled and this is
referring to a couple of different
things
uncanceled in terms of the right has
seen
covet guidelines as not
public health uh uh needs
but rather as the cancellation of
american people of american business etc
so
cpac uncanceled in one way means the
uncancelling of things that were
cancelled due to
covid they also are now waging this
so-called war against
cancel culture so so kind of a double
meaning here's a voicemail i got
about really what they mean by cancel
culture take a listen to this
hey david adam from layton utah here
yes i want to say that
cancel culture is really just another
form of
victimhood from the uh
right-wing conservatives in america
and who what's going on there why are
they
why does victimhood appeal so much
i don't know help me make sense of this
thing yeah i i don't know about
victimhood is so appealing to the right
victimhood is useful to the right and
if you listen to donald trump's cpac
speech yesterday
if you listen to donald trump's entire
presidency and
everybody around him and right-wing
media for a party
and a political movement that has
claimed for decades to be about
personal responsibility the degree to
which they have made themselves
the victims of everything is quite
stunning it really is
donald trump has been treated unfairly
by the media
the right has been treated unfairly by
public health officials it's all
they are the endless uh victims
all the time and i i
from a psychological standpoint i'd be
interested to learn more about what it
is that makes it appealing to them i
think it's politically useful
i think right-wing elected officials
republican elected officials have
realized
that particularly the the sort of
right-wing populists
that the rhetoric of victimhood about
how
they are trying to fight for you but
everybody's attacking them
it fits in very neatly with this
right-wing populist
faux populist rhetoric that they uh
endlessly repeat and promote even though
it links in absolutely no way to the
actual policies that they put
forward so for me it's more about
political utility
and they've been self-victimizing when
it comes to how they're being treated
on social media networks ignoring that
the stuff that's in violation of the
terms of service is coming
overwhelmingly from them they ignore
that they look only
at a sort of consequences-based approach
and then of course what that gets you to
is they believe they should be free of
consequences there shouldn't be any
consequences
to the things that they do or the things
that they say and any consequences to
their speech or actions by definition
are them being attacked but this
unfortunately because this has worked so
well at building
uh of this this very strange political
coalition that now exists on the right
because it's worked well i i expect it
to stay for a long time
um but i'm curious to hear from people
in the audience psychologically what
makes this vic
victim is self-victimization so so
appealing
is there something beyond just its
utility that makes it appealing
we have a great bonus show for you today
speaking of cancel culture
we will talk about the latest weapon in
the culture wars mr potato head
yeah we'll also talk about some very
interesting new studies
relating to uh dreams and the meaning
and significance of dreams and utility
and also we will talk about the doctor
fired after giving away expiring doses
of the covet vaccine i got a trash what
i call a trash vaccine
i rescued a dose from the trash by being
on an on-call list
i got my second dose friday um a doctor
was fired
for making use of those about to be in
the trash vaccines we will talk about
all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary showerhead that
saves you money by using
45 less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman